i was a teacher for 10 years in
kalamazoo public schools they're a
midsize urban district in southwest
michigan
and my first three years i taught
algebra 1 geometry algebra 2 the core
math classes but i also taught an
introductory statistics course and then
in my fourth year teaching i started
teaching ap statistics and taught it for
my last seven years teaching i love how
ap courses really stretch students and
give them a chance to
really challenge themselves and take on
a subject and a curriculum that is just
a little bit harder than
a standard high school curriculum might
be for them
and it prepares them for a level of
rigor in college that can be
intimidating for a lot of students when
they first enter a college course but
students who take ap classes
in my experience tend to feel more
comfortable once they get to college i
discovered khan academy when
a co-worker of mine showed it to me and
this was back when khan academy first
started and
a co-worker showed it to me and i could
actually get students the practice they
needed
often they needed it at home as well
because our students would for various
reasons miss a lot of days of school and
so getting students the help they needed
in the class or outside of the classroom
khan academy was a great help when i was
an ap teacher
i liked to use a variety of methods for
engaging my students with the concepts
we were learning so i would some some
days like to give a lecture on the
material or other days maybe play a game
or do a simulation or maybe other days
let them be self-paced in some review
problems
and khan academy offers a way for
teachers to do that in their classrooms
you have content creators like myself
working at khan academy who have been
teachers teaching ap for many years
and we also have external reviewers who
work closely with the college board and
who are table readers and grade the ap
test all working together to make sure
that the content is high quality for
students my entire career as a teacher i
felt like i was doing the world good by
teaching
multiple groups of students a subject
that i thought was would be incredibly
useful for their
professional academic and everyday lives
because teaching statistics i feel like
i'm equipping students with how to make
informed decisions in their lives